so I was recently re-watching everything
everywhere all at once for the manyth
time and enjoying Michelle Yo's amazing
performance but afterwards I found out
her part was actually written for
another actor I was like what so I
looked into actors who took a role
originally written for another actor
turns out there are some huge ones
everything everywhere all at once was
the breakout hit of 2022 wait was it
also the breakout hit of all things
universes and timelines I don't know I'm
gonna stick to the timeline and universe
we know and here it was a big old smash
it was anchored around the insanely fun
performance Michelle yo gave as she
moved from character to character
University Universe being a general
badass so it must have been written with
her in mind right nope turns out the
directors the Daniels totes had Jackie
Chan in mind when they wrote it but when
they hit the casting phase they were
having trouble like envisioning Jackie
or any dude for that matter playing the
part and they also realized they knew
the perfect woman for it already
Michelle yo she was actually cast as a
different part in the movie already and
they said she felt like family like
their aunt they shifted gears so hard
they decided that if she said no they
might just bail on the movie altogether
no pressure Auntie Michelle just the
fate of a hit Movie in Your Hands
fortunately she left at the chance and
the rest is history or present or future
I'm still fuzzy on how the Multiverse
works you guys speaking of things being
a little fuzzy when Idris Elba starred
in The Suicide Squad in 2021 it was
unclear if he was replacing Will Smith
who had starred in the previous version
director James Gunn and Elba himself
tried to unfuzzy it saying that he
wasn't replacing anyone gone even
created a new character called
Bloodsport but anyone with the power of
human observation could see Bloodsport
was basically a rehashed version of Will
Smith's dead shot they both had not so
great attitudes or full metal masks and
had basically one person who meant
anything to them their daughter then
there was the Teensy little detail that
Smith had actually signed on to return
as Deadshot but ended up backing out so
yeah while Gunn with Idris playing along
tried to use the force to pull out these
aren't the droids you're looking for on
us it was pretty transparent that it
just was playing a role literally
written for Will Smith from the previous
movie and speaking of blowing fast ones
I just found out that the rock wasn't
the original choice for Hobbes in the
Fast and the Furious series so who were
they after before him another mustly
action star yeah no it was Tommy Lee
Jones and no offense but he was
literally 65 years old at that point I'm
not trying to be ageist here but would
they have written a broken hip into the
script if he got one while filming I kid
I'm sure he would have been great in his
own way but it's pretty hilarious to me
that the two options for Hobbes were
Tommy Lee Jones and the Rock it's like
if they said our top two choices for the
next Marvel hero are Zendaya or Dame
Maggie Smith it was also hilarious to
find out why they ended up offering the
the role to the Rock once Tommy was out
according to Vin Diesel a random fan
named Jen Kelly told him that she'd love
to see him and The Rock on screen
together so he talked to the producers
and they offered Johnson the role I'm
sorry what they're making huge decisions
about blockbuster movies based on the
input of Jen Kelly random fan that's
wild another wild one was the casting
process for Beverly Hills Cop at the
time it was unheard of for a comedian
like Eddie Murphy to play an action star
which is probably why the first script
for BH cop a nickname for the movie I
just came up with called for Sylvester
Stallone to play Axel Foley he was even
signed on until two weeks before
shooting started but Sly was secretly
rewriting the script removing all the
comedy elements from it and changing it
into a standard action flip he changed
the ending to have him driving a tricked
out Lambo and doing a game of chicken
with a freight train that the bad guy
was in he made a ton of other big
changes too including making his
character's name Axel cabretti the folks
at Paramount were finally like okay
that's probably enough Rocky we'll catch
you on the next one Sly took his ideas
for the movie including the last name
cobretti and just repurposed elements of
it for his movie Cobra so things worked
out just fine for him but the studio had
a mad scramble to find a replacement
luckily Eddie Murphy agreed and the
movie raked in more than any other that
year speaking of showing us the money
let's talk about Jerry Maguire show me
the money writer and director Cameron
Crowe wrote the part of Jerry Maguire
for Tom Hanks but he was too swapped to
take it on he was actually getting ready
to direct his own movie For the First
Time The Incredible that thing you do so
Cameron had to find his next Jerry he
turned to an equally big star in Tom
Cruise who signed on but in a very
cruise-like move they spent the next
nine months making sure the script was
perfect for Cruz and hey mission
accomplished it even got Cruz and Oscar
not TBH both Jerry Maguire and that
thing you do are water Classics so I
don't think anybody made a bad decision
there Jurassic Park is another classic
and it almost starred none other than
Indiana Jones himself Harrison Ford the
director Steven Spielberg heard of him
had already worked with Ford and all the
Indiana Jones flicks so he was ready to
get that magic going again with a bunch
of dinosaur co-stars but for unknown
reasons Ford said no so Spielberg cast
Sam Neal as the male lead in the movie
Alan Grant in retrospect the real stars
were the dinos anyway so it worked just
fine either way Sam Neal killed it and
the movie was a monster hit sadly
Harrison Ford was never heard from again
all this is just a reminder that even if
you get offered a huge Hollywood roll
you might end up getting replaced by
like the rock or Tom Cruise sorry about
that you did your best and I'm proud of
you either way anyway if you could think
of other actors who starred in roles
written for other people hit us up in
the comments